citizens of the reject Nation welcome once
again to Our Last of Us episode 6 this time
reaction review experience Tara Erickson joining
me once again how you doing Tara I'm here
and I'm in leopard you are you look so cool
right now right you should be in the next
Wonder Woman film please absolutely we are
the noobs my friends ever grateful to Greg
for pairing us together because this has been
such a blast and ever grateful to you guys
as well for keeping it that way so uh keep
up the good work and as always if you want
to get notified every time one of these reactions
or anything else interesting on the channel
drops hit the Subscribe button and about the
bell ring the bell and don't forget to leave
a like on this video that helps arguably the
most out of anything and if you want to get
the full experience all the things that get
cut out of these reaction highlights come
on over to patreon.com the real rejects sync
up with your own copy of The Last of Us and
enjoy the experience alongside Tara and I
don't forget as well to check out Greg and
Andrew's Last of Us reactions for the pro
Gamers perspective and uh if you want to support
the channel in a different way maybe check
out our little merch shop especially this
brand new who influences the influencers shirt
that Greg designed isn't that sweet Tara this
is going that's for you here with me good
all right I think we're ready to go let's
let's do this let's let's jump into it [Applause]
[Music]
oh my God please learn this on guitar so you
can play it I'm gonna learn it you should
I think there are probably tabs out there
and then I'll come in as the yellow fungus
I know I still and then I could all do like
an interpretive dance yeah this could go viral
you you gotta work on it viral viral or fungal
oh time Jump a mile outside of Boston
baby wolves and baby rabbits oh it's a symbol
for the Lost Innocence
and the gun oh take the gun out two fingers
only put it Out Of Reach
I'm looking for my brother oh I ain't seen
him I haven't told you what he looks like
you look anything like you bit no I ain't
seen him I need you to tell us where we are
we're somewhere here exactly where and your
answer better be the same as your wife's oh
you're telling the truth yeah are you telling
me the truth
well you found a great place to hide I guess
anywhere people used to be you can't go there
no more so you haven't heard the name Tommy
nope we get those in the summer
not to pass the river death some Infected
some not if your brother is west of the river
he's gone oh boy you're not gonna scare us
you scared him foreign
I like those too
oh just the cold air all of a sudden uh you're
having a panic attack Joel there's some caves
along the river we'll set up camp there across
in the morning she's stolen two rabbits we
can get our own rabbits you're gonna teach
me how yeah hunting Montage yay hmm
can I have some no what just to warm up let
her have some sharp kids just to warm up
so gross she immediately grows a five o'clock
shadow say we find the fireflies it all works
where are you going what are you doing an
old farmhouse some land a ranch cool yeah
I would raise sheep they're quiet I don't
know what they're told sell the wool make
your own coats Joel I read everything I could
in the school library Neil Armstrong Buzz
Aldrin Jim Lovell do you know who my favorite
is it's Charlie Ryan
best astronaut name ever surely and don't
call me Shirley it'll work right the vaccine
it's a little late to start wondering uh you
should see the debate now get some sleep dream
of sheep ranches on the moon oh that's a sweet
way to say we'll stick together kid no I really
want to see a sheep Ranch on the moon at the
end of this show that's what I'm is foreshadowing
Tara what are you talking about I woke up
early you were passed out so I took second
watch you can't do things like this but I
can hey man I'm a natural you are of this
world
God that makes me cold just looking at it
I love it I'll take all the cold too cold
John it's beautiful though it's so beautiful
it is it is the river of death still no people
y'all should find some all-white outfits though
you're wandering in the snow and dressed like
Andrew W.K out here
Boston is just beautiful gotta go there someday
I know we're not still in Boston in case anybody
wondered about that joke
down
[Laughter] nice put that in the pun book look
at that River Hey Joe what if this is the
river of death what makes you say that oh
cause the dam is holding back the uh oh no
oh no hello nope okay we're looking for any
trouble we're just passing through drop the
gun oh dang it you think five steps back how
about we just talk this through how about
you shut the [__] up okay that easy Coral
she's still got a gun you've been near infected
there's no infected out here the hell they're
right
no no no no fact that he will smell it and
he will rip you up oh boy
thank you
like I said we'll just move on now her damn
it you faked us out dog train you to do that
oh boy okay [Music] he can't sniff out special
blood [Music] oh boy oh Joel Don't Panic dude
don't panic oh God oh thank God [Music]
[Laughter] that's lovely what are you doing
out here just looking for my brother it's
all nothing more we haven't seen any brothers
here or sisters or otherwise what's your name
Joel
[Music] oh God they know
foreign
the operation it's funny how the past becomes
the present too this does feel just like an
old west white Fort or something
[Music] Snowman
oh my God what oh Thomas oh [Music] damn I
wasn't expecting to see him [Music] oh guys
come here to save you [Laughter] oh these
guys oh
wow that's like summer camp and also that
made me teary-eyed it's beautiful there's
more if you need it thank you ma'am been a
while since we've had a proper meal actually
I don't think I've ever had a proper meal
let's mind our manners what what's wrong with
you what about her manners kids around here
don't usually look or talk like you right
well maybe I'll teach them
I think maybe y'all got a little off on the
wrong foot who's gonna have our guys kill
us well you got to be real careful about who
we let in this place well you got a couple
of nine-year-olds shooting themselves out
there yeah we're grateful for your hospitality
and all but it'd be nice to have a moment
here maybe just for family oh Maria is family
dang don't say congrats manners Joel congrats
I'll give them a moment it's a 700 but I found
a variable Power Scope sub MOA and headshot
those folks from a half mile out you teach
me how no we can't how do you keep this place
quiet carefully it's not advertising what
we have staying off the radio we draw power
from a dam got that working a couple years
ago this place actually [__] works
all we need now is the moon everything you
see in our town greenhouses livestock all
shared Collective ownership so uh communism
leave this place immediately that's our newest
one a couple months old you want a pet her
ah what's your name I love Shimmer some new
clothes we can put them in the empty house
across the street from us yeah pretty much
untouched and so three but it's got the Heat
going in it do worse oh trust me we have been
we've been doing fine oh oh Joel thanks for
still giving a [__] about me working on
raising some Hogs too once we get bacon I
mean what's even left
so how's Tess oh she's fine oh all right and
the kid she's the daughter of some Firefly
muckety muck no they got a base down at the
University of Eastern Colorado a week's Ride
Shop oh boy yeah I can't go what cause your
wife won't let you no she's the one who kept
you off the radio is that why you stopped
messaging me back oh they didn't have to take
me in but they did and all they asked is that
I follow that rule I'm your brother they're
very protective of this place and you just
got here if you knew the [__] that I've
been through Tommy trying to find you these
last few months I'm gonna be a father oh of
course but I don't know why feel like I'd
be a good dad I believe in you I guess we'll
find out that's all you got what else am I
supposed to say just because life stopped
for you it doesn't mean it has to stop for
me oh boy go grab some supplies and be out
of your hair in the morning oh dude you just
got here gotta open yourself up to someone
Joel [Music]
the poll it's Christmas Story all over again
oh no it looks just like her oh Sarah
oh my
gross
[Laughter] oh she's the best that's great
oh oh in memoriam you were looking at the
little Memorial Tommy made I'm sorry about
your kids it's okay just Kevin Sarah was Joel's
daughter laughs Revelation look I'm not going
to ask you what you're doing with him good
but there are clearly things you don't know
about Joel oh like how he used to kill people
I know about that and Tommy did it too are
you worried about him Tommy was following
Joel the way you are now well maybe I'm smarter
than Tommy no offense [Laughter] that'd be
a super eggplant coat the movies movies what
let's do this oh God Ellie's gonna stay forever
Tony's you know Tony DeForest that's nice
I'm an actor too Nothing Like Richard Dreyfus
for the apocalypse this ride to the university
as it is that mission just just pair and do
what you do you've had people go that way
and come back and all of them what is this
I'll Trust she's immune she got infected but
she didn't get sick that was months ago months
she's in oh boy it was Marlene she hired us
to smuggle her to some fireflies it went bad
test got bit uh there you go you know she
saved my life there from another kid five
years ago I would have destroyed him but she
had to shoot him to save me I saw a Man kill
his own brother and today I thought that dog
was gonna tear apart because it smelled something
on her and all I did was stand there I couldn't
think of anything he said just oh so far oh
Joe yeah PTSD man I have dreams remember I
just know that when I wake up I've lost something
oh it's all I've ever done failure you want
me to take her I'm just going to get her killed
I know it Joe I mean it's what you took off
on me right to make up for the things we did
oh you're younger than me you're still strong
you said it yourself you'll come back you
have to take her Ellie will never let that
happen yeah Tommy you're the only one I trust
if anyone else sees those bites on her what's
under her skin so shoot her to the last thing
I'll ever ask oh Bravo performance yeah what
a scene I'll take her out of dawn oh boy oh
boy something feels ominous and not right
right now yeah I don't feel like this is gonna
go off as planned we all they had to worry
about boys movies and which shirt goes with
which skirt the grand time you missed out
on I came here to talk to you no why are you
still here if you're gonna ditch me ditch
me oh I made this decision for your own good
he knows the area better than I do you don't
give a [__] about me or not of course
I do and what are you so afraid of exactly
that I'm not her you know oh all right Ellie
I'm sorry about your daughter Joel I have
lost people too you have no idea what loss
is everybody I have cared for has either died
or left me yeah everybody except for you so
don't tell me that I'd be safe with somebody
else because the truth is I would just be
more scared
you're not my daughter I'm not sure as hell
ain't your dad now come down we're going our
separate ways oh what dude
oh my God I get it but also I get it come
on I'm mad right now I can't keep pushing
people away gotta accept the progress of time
what the frick else are you gonna do Joel
[Music] to watch [Music]
here we go there's no way that that wife is
gonna let him Tommy go yes some shoes got
a drop in control as it should be
what a lovely cabin this needs to be like
a last minute run to the airport in a rom-com
and Joel is like I'm waiting with you wait
that needs to that needs to happen go to her
Joel yeah I came here to steal one of these
horses and go I would have gave you one that
was 30 minutes ago and I guess you deserve
a choice I still think you'd be better off
with Tom let's go hahaha
yep yes sir naughty Oaks Big Brother [Music]
go with God take some whiskey with you sure
gonna need it
[Music] oh practice oh fun you're flinching
the target's too small I made it bigger than
I should have I'm not quenching rifle just
sucks you squeeze the trigger like you love
it it's gentle but steady nice and slow you're
gonna shoot this thing or get it pregnant
dang
[Music] [Laughter] [Music] I love it got that
a-hole beautiful shot I guess it was an H
hole there but this building that's right
houses stores that kind of thing we were called
contractors it's a contractor that's pretty
cool so cool we're cool everybody loved contractors
that's right man very important job should
be more celebrated roof is an important job
I don't know what Tommy was so afraid of still
time to find out still come to find out
[Laughter] I don't want to hang out with Ellie
I don't see any fireflies though they're probably
in the middle safer oh damn we're here I don't
want a sheep Ranch actually I mean if the
dealers I can do anything that's the deal
when I was a kid I wanted to be a singer yes
yes uh sing a song It's Gonna Echo so well
in these Chambers will you sing it for me
later I want to save the [__] world matters
the least you can do for me the Acoustics
were perfect right back there are those monkeys
from the old Labs oh
[Music] okay no guards gun
yeah get it out just the growth alone there
arm up [Music] no harm better befall this
horse I know The Walking Dead traumatized
me from that [Music]
a little bit of a sailing drip left over yeah
I would take some of that there are definitely
doctors here there's a packing list something
to make before moving they just left
were they headed to Salt Lake City did it
say it's cool like in a game when you grab
a document like the ways they they put little
moments that feel kind of like a gameplay
thing yeah subtly [Music]
damn you monkeys at least it ain't clickers
yeah no fireflies either maybe in all that
research they turned into monkeys monkey could
rip you apart yeah was that a baboon a Capuchin
a chimp three hours later he's named all the
monkeys that's where they went the pins lead
there better facilities I don't know oh boys
no don't are they gonna steal a horse
what are these Raiders
[Music]
[__] [__] [__] [Music]
ah
conserve
whoa adrenaline ow okay it's a railroad spike
oh okay belt belt I don't know of course damn
it [__] Ellie's gonna do it come on Ellie
come on Ellie come on now you have to save
Joel oh Jesus shoot shoot shoot oh God
yes yes oh my God I think we're safe we gotta
stop the bleeding yeah
I hope you know how to sew come on come on
come on don't open your eyes open your eyes
Joy you gotta get up
Joe oh no no no no no no no no [Music]
what is this song are you trying to make me
scream cry right now
oh shut up
no [Music] why look I know it's I I don't
actually know I don't think Joe can be dead
but also they'll put you through stuff in
shows and games like these they they'll count
on you saying that to yourself and then pull
the rug out from under you there's no way
he had to have taught her like first aid but
also why wouldn't she like shoving some tissue
in there to stop the bleeding yeah and I gotta
have like a suture or something in there in
their kit you would think so him anything
can happen why what a what a what an experience
I feel emotionally drained same now let's
review the episode yeah oh my gosh yeah right
dude this show is like roller coaster after
roller coaster absolutely like wow this has
been fascinating and I like I really enjoyed
this episode because this one I mean you know
by the time you get to the end there is more
Intrigue and Peril and suspense but so much
of this was you know there is an ominous feeling
around you don't know exactly who to trust
or or how to kind of apply you know the the
commune especially to the rest of the world
and kind of you know Orient yourself in terms
of how you're supposed to feel it's very lovely
and so much of this episode you spend there
and so much of it is traveling without you
know the immediate dangers and so a lot of
this was like really nice to spend time in
yeah and to just kind of drink in visually
for the scenery and for the atmosphere um
but yeah like the way they also extrapolated
the emotion and the way that they've you know
kind of been almost like nomadically between
these episodes showing you just like these
different characters lives as you have Joel
and Ellie kind of through lining at all I
think has been really interesting and very
rich you know and very effecting yeah you
see how much they have grown together which
is why I was glad the one he showed up towards
the end because I was like there's no way
you can't split them up just like I'm saying
right now he can't be dead I know hug I really
like though that they take so much time um
just showing us like how they live and going
through things and seeing them just like talk
like skip to they're on the horse and they're
talking about all these different things Joel
teaching Ellie about how the world used to
be um and I think it's uh it's so sweet and
then it just really shows us how closed off
Joel is where he's like you're right even
after Ellie says all these nice things he's
like you're right you're not my daughter I'm
sure as hell not your dad yeah and he just
like leaves don't get close to me yeah like
you think that it's gonna he might just like
open up sort of like he said uh I'll have
a sheep farm on the moon that's like his little
way but it keeps it's there's that threshold
with him where it's like no he he'll take
one step over and then he'll like 10 10 steps
back yeah it's like it's like the yeah yeah
it's like he's got a line of closeness and
if you get too close and too you know reminiscent
of of especially the life before and and what
the feelings must have been you know just
having that relationship still you know alive
and vital with Sarah like they do a really
nice job of of having those debates and those
character responses in a way that never feels
contrived or feels like the plot demands its
uh you know like the the reunion between him
and Tommy yeah in this I thought was really
nicely handled like you can feel both the
the brotherly love that they have but also
the tension from so much time from the things
they did at the beginning of the outbreak
uh and the ways they've both really changed
and it's funny because we've seen you know
Tommy through Joel's perspective so much in
you know the intervening episodes between
the first one and now and I really love the
way that they kind of get you know it's like
we saw Tommy last before everything went to
[__] and now we're seeing him again in
a different place where it does feel like
all this time has passed and he has grown
and and changed even though we haven't spent
all that time with him yeah um so I just hats
off to both the the actors especially but
also the writing like I think the writing
is really thoughtful and does well to you
know keep you grounded in the world but also
engrossed in the experiences characters are
having you know yeah yeah yeah they did a
great a great job of like showing us how his
brother has moved on without him saying it
he never said like hey man like they do in
other TV shows hey man look I've moved on
I've moved like they do that all the time
and I hate it so much that's like I'm like
oh God come on and so of course in the show
they do a really good job of not being expositional
they just like show us the stuff and it's
it was um also nicely surprising like when
he grabbed her hand it was like oh oh yeah
all right um and I also like that he he didn't
tell him right away like oh she's pregnant
I'm expecting a child it sort of had to come
out yeah um yeah out of like a desperate moment
because there's so much yeah of just like
life development that he's had that then is
forced into these brief exchanges yeah instead
of you know having a nice dinner and like
talking about life and then having it come
up it's more just like okay you got your mission
so I I have to use this information functionally
rather than emotionally uh you know to sort
of say why I cannot take on this this risk
necessarily yeah and just those those debates
and the way they realize the commune I thought
like the commune is so lovely you know and
uh you just want to spend you just want to
hang out there you just want to like spend
a bunch of time there and even the thing with
the couple at the beginning like I I like
it's like I get the sense that throughout
these episodes they're probably doing things
that yeah are are game related you're probably
going to environments and and parts of the
country that you would Traverse in the game
but I feel like throughout each of these episodes
they will add or maybe you know in the case
of like a bill and Frank vastly expand on
just other human characters and their experiences
so I love that you just have this couple living
remote you know out off the land you know
kind of almost you know like they're they're
like a Native American couple so it's it's
almost like seeing them and then just thinking
about the Heritage there is interesting because
it almost seems like they're sort of unbothered
like like his wife is just so chill you know
and uh and just the way that they interact
with Joel and Ellie and the way that they
have that sort of tense but completely relaxed
standoff yeah that's so great and and a great
opportunity for like a you know the at least
I didn't recognize the woman but the the guy
is like a character actor you've seen in a
bunch of stuff and so like it's cool to have
you know actors like that be able to show
up on a show like this leave an impression
even if it is just like a brief little scene
yeah and it was also as if to say their life
before the change of the world was the same
as it is then now that what we're seeing in
the present moment it's like not much has
changed for us yeah they choose they chose
to live that way before the [__] came
yeah lucky she agreed to go out there with
him because it worked out and she did not
want to I love that scent and she's like I
didn't want to she's just sitting there like
in a rocking chair and it just took what the
second she said that I was like man I bet
you she just landed there in that house out
in the middle of nowhere and was like I don't
think I want to be this secluded but then
she just like at least I have my rocking chair
yeah like that's just like her life and now
yeah like the world crashes and it's like
all right well hey I got the rocking chair
I'm doing better than most people yeah I have
earned the right to be so chill yeah yeah
a guy came with a gun I'll make you some soup
yes I love that too you made soup and the
whole thing about like did you tell them did
you tell them the truth are you telling me
the truth like this is so great so good and
uh and yeah like I liked that the commune
stuff you know it's like you're constantly
and I think the walking dead it's interesting
to watch this show post Walking Dead because
there are ways in which sure they're quite
similar they're drawing from similar cloth
in terms of motifs and and genres genre tropes
and elements and things like that um although
they are very different in sensibility and
so it's like in a The Walking Dead kind of
primed me to go like okay somebody there's
some evil secret beneath this communist gotta
be something messed up about this and and
maybe maybe not Tommy but you know maybe his
wife or maybe somebody here is is gonna be
you know uh particularly vile or terrible
or do something to Joel or Ellie or whatever
and and they set you up for that you know
with that you know don't go past the river
you know there's Dead Infected that we find
dead people like there there's some you know
Insidious or there's some you know uh very
just Dark Matter lying Beyond yeah exactly
like there's something sinister out there
be it human or otherwise don't go there and
then you get there and you're like no this
is like beautiful yeah and that whole thing
about like if you hit just because you have
a certain reputation doesn't necessarily mean
you are that way and you kind of understand
you're like yeah I get why you would want
everyone to think that there's a big bad lurking
out there because they're not gonna go there
and then you're gonna be fine you know like
you're gonna be relatively unbothered by things
and yeah just like really well thought out
and the way they weave it all together with
the travel is like beautiful to look at is
like beautiful to just spend time it makes
you want to go travel yeah even despite like
I like that it's like there are moments between
I think that happens sometimes like you have
a zombie or a you know an outbreak or whatever
kind of horror tindered show or movie and
there's I feel like sometimes a pressure to
make it feel like everything is kind of always
permeated by the bleakness whereas yeah you
know in a situation like this 20 years on
yeah there there have to be in between moments
where things are just kind of chill or Pleasant
or beautiful or you know anything in between
and those help to really then create that
contrast for when you see like when you're
out at the University and uh you know it's
things just feel wrong and off and you're
like okay now I'm very tense again and it's
cool because it allows you to kind of just
react and have the tension build from your
own suspicion just as much as from what the
show's actually giving you yeah which is nice
and also to think about that people were saying
once you go past the river of death it's not
because people are dying it's because they're
staying in the commune yeah unless they were
stepped out it's literally like now that you
think about they're you know they're not dead
they're just like oh yeah that's way better
I'm not going back yeah like obviously this
is where all the people are the dead ones
are probably just the scavengers or people
who aren't going to you know who just want
to plunder or pillage you know exactly yeah
which I and I also like that they give you
some brevity when we when we land there because
in initially in the beginning we're not sure
exactly what's going to happen and then you
kind of have fun times but then you like you
said you allow your emotions to kind of get
to you along with the very good music that
they have in this yeah uh that carries us
throughout to go like what is waiting behind
the corner yeah uh yeah it's they do a great
job of that yeah and the tangibility to like
it's so it's such a relief when you know it's
it's cathartic when Joel and Tommy finally
reunite and it's such a relief when they're
like actually having a real meal and Ellie
gets to take another like probably her second
actual shower yeah in the whole series yeah
and and those moments too I I I'm sure other
things have done it certainly but this show
does a really nice job of frequently kind
of checking in on that making you kind of
as a viewer grateful for like I can get a
nice meal I can take a shower I can't have
a bed the the basics of Life are are quite
accessible at least here for us so you know
those resonate and then create an even better
contrast when you're back out in the cold
and you're camping in the dark and you're
trying to eat rabbits and stuff yes yeah yeah
great in the way it lets you live in it and
I'm sure that the game didn't didn't do this
but I wanted Ellie she yelled at that girl
in the summer camp room was like what are
you looking at like I wanted Ellie to find
kind of another friend again like a girl who
was a friend to sort of maybe talk to her
about like so what do you think like are there
like boys that I don't know what the girl
would say but she's in a commune she might
want to know more about how Ellie got the
way that she is and I would have found that
conversation very intriguing and or hilarious
absolutely because Ellie is like a little
replica of Joel and she would have been like
I don't know what the [__] you're talking
about girl but like you need to get it together
do you want to go like hunting like I just
would have liked to see that with Ellie and
not a normal girl but a girl who's in the
commune and thinking about how Ellie was saying
it's weird how she's thinking about skirts
and shoes and boys and feelings when Ellie's
like I just need to survive I would have liked
to see that contrast with her yeah have her
find like a peer who has grown up here but
also knows this kind of more normal lifestyle
yeah instead of just alt fedra and labs and
qz stuff yeah yeah for sure yep but across
the board like really nice character beats
really nice acknowledgment of the history
you know Joel withholding the information
about tests then it coming out later like
all those things felt very natural uh his
you know Reflections on and reluctance to
talk about Sarah just the way they they have
that little Memorial like all those things
feel so lived in and yeah like the Great Moments
between Joel and Tommy especially and they
had me going like I thought like maybe maybe
the next episode will be a Tommy episode or
something like that like you know they as
much as you're like no Joe and Ellie probably
at the back of your mind you're like they
have to continue on at the same time I'm you
know they draw this in a way where I'm like
but anything could happen you know yeah like
him lying there bleeding out I'm like if I
if hey that he going to be dead because HBO
does those kinds of things they do they do
and that's yeah it's like you can never get
too calm but uh but so far this has been terrific
and this was yeah this was a really interesting
feeling episode yeah because so much of it
is about warming up to letting yourself you
know be open to you know a little bit of warmth
and letting your guard down and you know kind
of opening back up and yeah you understand
the reluctance on Joel's part especially and
I just continue to love the way that he and
Ellie go back and forth and have friction
in the way that she is pulling him slowly
out of his his cave and next time we gotta
get Joel singing a song we need some Joel
musical numbers I expect a musical episode
I bet you it's gonna happen I'm gonna make
I'm gonna make a guess I bet you it's going
to happen when they're there and they're doing
some vaccine thing but Ellie is like having
a tough time maybe she's like almost gonna
die they're taking her blood I don't know
but she's like almost maybe going to die and
Joel starts to sing to her yes yes there you
go sings her back to life you can cry him
back to life in the beginning of the next
one he can sing her back to life later well
Hells yeah Tara Erickson is there anything
you want to say to the people before we Boogie
no accepted I love you we love you so be well
thank you guys for being so cool as always
leave your thoughts down in the comments below
no spoilers but you know that you guys are
Jiggy big you're so money baby leave a like
subscribe check out the patreon and last but
not least let's end this with a patron of
the day shout out
pandemic and demagoons I'm surprised we haven't
got to you on the last of us yet but you are
the one I mean you know you could be patient
zero with the name like pandemic Jones or
you could be the guy to call in a pandemic
and who knows what to do yeah so another person
whom we would like to join our apocalypse
Survivor party you are invited as long as
you're cool with me Kanye Pandy I think that
is a that is a benefit like you can Jones
you can listen right there sure right good
company you know supplies water food also
nickname Pandy yeah so uh from now on you're
Pandy and uh your Grandy and we are happy
to have you here at the patreons stay pledged
buddy and uh we'll catch you next let's get
Randy Randy with Pandy that's your new podcast
style you got is it adult theme yeah
see you next month [Music]